the meat is juicy the skin is crispy and
let me just tell you the showstopper is
the gravy it brings everything together
hey everybody it's your girl mikko food
blogger and recipe developer over at
mikko in the dish you can catch me on
instagram at mikko and the dish i think
one of the most essential recipes that
everyone needs in their arsenal is a
good roasted chicken today i'm going to
show you all my tips and tricks to make
the perfect crispiest juiciest most
flavorful roasted chicken and i'm going
to show you how to make a homemade gravy
to go with it all right y'all let's get
cooking the key to achieving the most
juiciest and golden brown chicken truly
is even cooking my preferred method is
spatchcocking and that's just where you
flatten out the chicken so that it's the
same thickness all around
like a doctor
where you get started spatchcocking make
sure that you remove the giblets these
are going to be used later for our gravy
so just set those aside i'm going to
take my bird and place it right on top
breast side down so you can see the back
one here what we're going to do is cut
along each side of the backbone to
remove it i find that the first cut is
always the hardest so i use both hands
to break through
do the same on the other side of the
bathtub
all right there goes our backbone i'm
going to save this as well what we want
to do is flatten the breast so we'll
flip over the chicken and i like to
place the thighs going outward and get
my hands securely in between the two
breasts and press down you should hear a
nice crack of the breast though
and that's how you snatch pocket chicken
it's really that easy so before we keep
going i'm going to show you how to make
my homemade adobo spice seasoning so you
can season any way that you like do ubu
just make sure that you season liberally
it needs to pack flavor i'm going to
start off with some turmeric oregano
onion powder garlic powder pepper and
salt and all you have to do is mix those
together all right now that everything's
mixed together it's all done now you
have homemade adobo seasoning we'll add
this to our chicken all right all right
let's go we're going to take half of our
adobo spice and add it into the back
cavity while you're doing this i want to
make sure that you are paying attention
to every single crevice of this chicken
and don't be shy rub it in
there is nothing more disappointing than
an under seasoned chicken let's flip the
bird over there's two more steps that i
need to take to ensure that i have a
crispy bird first i take a skewer and i
poke the skin all around this is going
to create channels for the fat to
release and crisp up the front of the
skin next i'm going to reposition my
bird so i'm going to use my fingers to
separate the skin from the meat i do
that over the breast area and i also do
it over the thigh and this is going to
create a pocket i'm going to take some
of this clarified butter and spread it
under the skin and i just use my fingers
to help guide it all along now it's time
to season the top of the word get it all
over oh this girl looks seasoned okay
now that my chicken is fully seasoned
i'm going to transfer it to a greased
rack i'm putting my chicken in the
fridge anywhere from an hour to 24 hours
just to make sure those seasons really
penetrate the bird my bird is ready to
roast but remember take it out from the
fridge 45 minutes ahead of time to make
sure that it gets to room temperature
this bird is going to roast at
475 degrees for about 50 minutes while
the chicken is roasting it's the perfect
time to make a gravy so remember those
inners that i told you to set aside
earlier i boiled them down until they
were nice and tender and now i'm going
to use them to flavor my gravy i like to
chop them up really finely so that they
incorporate nice and smoothly into my
gravy i'm adding butter to a saucepan
and just letting it melt now i'm gonna
add some onions and some garlic i'm
gonna let the onions and garlic cook for
one minute until they're nice and soft
that looks good now i'm gonna add my
flour looking good let's add our chopped
giblets
[Music]
now i'm going to switch to a whisk and
i'm going to add in my stock
finally i like to add worcestershire
sauce it uh worcestershire
worcestershire finally i like to add
worcestershire sauce it adds a deep
umami flavor and rounds out the gravy
now that my gravy has reached a boil i'm
going to add in my babies reduce the
heat to low to let your gravy thicken
then add salt and pepper to taste
mmm
that is perfect so now i'm going to set
this aside and get my chicken my chicken
is out the oven it's been resting for
about 10 minutes you guys the skin is
nice and crispy the color is golden
brown it is perfection all that's left
to do is to carve it to remove the leg
quarter i grab the leg and pull it up
away from the body and then i slice
right between the leg and the body
uh-huh
that simple you can actually see the
indentation of the center breastbone i'm
going to follow along that breastbone
and cut just to the side of it guys and
that's it that's how you easily carve
your chicken breast all that's left to
do is add that homemade gravy that i
made earlier right over the top guys i
have been waiting hours to try this
chicken i am so excited it is time to
dig in
[Music]
i shed a chest here the chicken is so
juicy this skin is so crispy this
chicken is incredible but don't take my
word for it try it out for yourself this
is worth your time so so good that's it
guys today i showed you how to make the
perfect roasted chicken and a delicious
homemade gravy to go with it if you like
this recipe leave a comment down below
let me know what you think or shoot me a
message on instagram at nico and the
dish until next time
peace yes
[Music]
you